is you know what is a derivative well
basically what a derivative is it's a
way of finding the instantaneous rate of
change and when you hear the word rate
of change what that means it's referring
to the slope so let me draw a diagram
here for us so basically what we have is
something that looks like this
okay we have a curve for example right
and we have two points on the curve
let's just say right here and right here
now if we go down to the x-axis okay
this is going to be X this distance
right here is X and if we go up to our
function this point here is going to be
X comma f of X okay so when you put that
x value into your function you get out
the Y value or the f of X value right
now if we go a little bit further to the
right okay let's just call this distance
H okay so with me so far
that means over here we're going X plus
h okay X plus h and if we go up to this
point on our graph right here we've got
X plus h if we put that into the
function the output or the Y value is f
of X plus h okay so all we've done is
we've just written this in a real
generic way but what we have is we have
two points on our curve and now what
we're gonna do is we're gonna find the
slope okay between those two points okay
now when you find the slope remember
your slope formula from algebra it's y2
minus y1 over x2 minus x1 right that's
our slope formula in this case it's
going to be f of X plus h ok that's that
Y value minus f of X right divided by x2
minus x1 so that's going to be X plus h
okay minus X and you can see here that
the X plus h minus X right you can see
that the X's are cancelling and we just
have each in the denominator right but
now let's take this a step further so
what we're doing right now is we're
actually finding the slope between these
two points which is the average rate of
change okay it's this average slope but
you can see that anywhere along this
graph the slope is constantly changing
like here okay it's that an angle like
so here it's a little bit less steep
here it's even less steep here it's even
less steep here it's even good turning
around and going the other direction
right so what we're doing is refining a
formula for the instantaneous rate of
change we'll get a slope at any point
along this curve and the way we do that
is we introduce limits and it's the
limit as H approaches 0 what that means
is that as this distance right here gets
smaller and smaller and smaller this
point here in a fact is moving along
this curve until these two points are
right on top of one another and that
distance is zero and so what we're
getting now is we're getting the
instantaneous rate of change instead of
this average rate of change so what
you're seeing right here and let me just
rewrite it a little bit is this is the
limit as H approaches 0 of f of X plus h
minus f of X all divided by H this is
referred to as the difference quotient
difference remember is subtracting
quotients dividing so altogether they
call this the difference quotient but
when you get to the end of precalculus
beginning of calculus they start to
refer to this as f prime of X which is
the derivative so don't get confused by
the the word derivative it's really just
a formula for the slope of the tangent
line okay the line that just barely
touches that graph at that one point and
it gives us the instantaneous rate of
change so let's get into a basic example
now say for example your function is
like this f of X equals x squared
okay so we've grown up as we've gone
along in math and we know what f of x
equals x squared looks like it's just a
parabola like so right but now what
we're gonna do is we're going to use our
derivative we're going to use our
difference quotient to find the
derivative okay which is a formula for
the slope of the tangent line at any
point along this graph so what we're
going to do is let's go ahead and do
these substitutions here we're going to
put in Max Plus H okay squared minus f
of X which is the original function
that's x squared all divided by H so if
we simplify this we get x squared plus 2
HX plus h squared minus x squared all
divided by H and it's the limit as H is
approaching zero right
now notice that the X Squared's are
cancelling each other out
and then here we can factor out an H
which gives us 2x plus h all divided by
H so those HS cancel and again remember
it's the limit as H approaches 0 if we
put 0 in for H we're left with 2x and
this is our formula for our derivative
which remember the derivative is just a
formula for the slope of the tangent
line so a simple example would be say we
were interested in finding the slope at
the point 2 4 okay right there okay so
we're trying to find the slope of that
tangent line well if we put in that
x-coordinate - okay and for X here
that's going to be F prime of 2 which is
equal to 2 times 2 which is equal to 4
and again remember this is a formula for
our slope so now we know that the slope
is 4 and it goes through the point 2 4
let's write an equation of the tangent
line so that's going to be Y minus y1
equals M times X minus x1 we're just
gonna use the point-slope form so this
is going to be Y minus 4 equals the
slope which is also 4 times X minus the
x-coordinate of the point which is 2 and
that's an equation for our tangent line
okay like so now let's get into another
example about you know we talked about
how to find it we talked about what it
is and another example of why it's
useful so you probably remember from
algebra 2 and precalculus when you're
graphing polynomials so take for example
this polynomial here f of x equals x
cubed minus 4x right so one way we would
graph this as we'd say all right let's
see if we can factor this and find the
zeros remember the zeros are just the
x-intercepts so if we factor this
further we get X plus 2 X minus 2 bring
down the axe if we set all these factors
equal to 0 you can see what we're
getting is we're getting zero we're
getting positive two if we set that one
to zero and we're getting negative 2 if
we set this group equal to 0 and we know
the leading coefficients positive ok
which tells us that the end behavior is
going up to the right and we know it's
an odd degree so that means it's going
the opposite direction to the left and
we
the graph goes something like that
through those points but the question
that students oftentimes have is when
you go through these points like how
high does that graph go before it turns
around does it go way up here and then
come back down here and go way back down
here and or does it just go a little bit
past the x-axis you know how do we find
that out how do we find those turning
points well what's interesting is is
that when the graph bends when it turns
ok say for example like this what's the
slope of the tangent line at that point
where it turns well you can see it's a
horizontal line so the slope of that
tangent line is zero so what we're going
to do is we're going to find the
derivative of our equation and we're
going to set that derivative equal to
zero so we can find the points on the
graph where the slope of the tangent
line is equal to zero okay so we're
going to use our difference quotient
again our derivative formula right here
and so let's do that so we've got X plus
h cubed minus 4 times X plus h minus f
of X which is original function so
that's going to be X cubed minus 4x all
divided by H okay now if I simplify this
this comes out 2x cubed plus 3x squared
H plus 3x H squared I'm using the
binomial expansion theorem here
distribute the negative 4 so that's
negative 4x minus 4-h distribute the
negative here that gives us negative x
cubed plus 4x and this is all divided by
H ok and you can see we get a lot of
cancellation the X cubes are cancelling
the 4 X's are cancelling and then if we
factor out an H out of what remains here
we get 3x squared plus 3x h plus h
squared minus 4 all divided by H you can
see those HS are cancelling but remember
it's the limit as H approaches 0 right
so if we put 0 in now for H this whole
term is going to go to 0 this whole term
is going to go to 0 and we're left with
3 x squared minus 4 is our derivative
okay that's a formula for our slope but
what we want to do is we want to find
out where that slope is 0 okay that's
where the graph is you know turning
around or bending and so what we're
going to do is we're going to add 4 to
both sides okay so that's 3 x squared
we're gonna divide both sides by 3
so that's
four-thirds we're going to take the
square root of both sides that gives us
plus or minus and I did this on the
calculator for us it's 1.15 okay now if
we put 1.15 back into our original
equation what we get is 1.15 comma
negative three point zero eight and if
we put a negative 1.15 we get positive
three point zero eight so those are our
turning points so if we graph this you
can see that negative one point one five
we're going to be up here at let's see
we're gonna be at three point zero eight
so it's gonna be right about there and
if we're at positive one point five
we're gonna be right about there so that
gives us a better idea okay of how high
the graph is going and how low the graph
is going otherwise we're just kind of
guessing we don't really know where
those extra Mar those maximums and those
minimums right so that's a key point and
again you can see where that graph is
bending or turning or changing direction
that's where the slope of the tangent
line is equal to zero so key points to
remember when you're learning about
derivatives is you know what is a
derivative it's really a formula for the
slope how do we find the slope we take
these two points okay and we use our
slope formula but we take it a step
further to go from the average rate of
change to the instantaneous rate of
change by using limits and the limit as
H gets smaller and smaller and
approaches zero and then from there once
you have the derivative you have a
formula for the slope of the tangent
line and you can you know use it in some
of these applications like we talked
about today so I hope this video helped
you understand what is the derivative
how is it useful you know and how to use
it
subscribe to the channel check out more
math tutoring videos on my youtube
channel Mario's math tutoring and I look
forward to helping you in the future
videos I'll talk to you soon